[Music]
[Music]
some strong words from dr. Anthony foul
to has had a key role in the management
of the pandemic Peter King spoke with
him for the Peter King podcast available
wherever you find your podcast and Peter
give me your big-picture overall
reaction to the things that dr. fowey
had to tell you I think there are two
mic number one he's bullish on the NFL
playing he thinks the NFL should play
fanless at first but he also thinks that
eventually during the season that fans
ought to be phased back into the games
and I think number two and most
importantly beware of the second wave
because these teams have hired these
infection control officers and I'm
telling him like these these people some
of whom already worked for the team they
might be the team trainer or whoever
really is up on infectious diseases
someone from every organization is gonna
have that role that role is going to be
so important because if you have some
week three four five people test
positive there's almost no way that that
team
go out and play if you're a team coming
in to play team X with four positive
tests on a Friday or a Saturday you tell
me if you're the player rep for team y
going in to play team X do you want to
play that team and do you recommend to
the players on your team that you guys
show up and play on Sunday I think
that's gonna be a big big issue big
issue no doubt about it this is
something Mike and I have talked about a
lot we talked about it a little
yesterday you know that's one thing I
would like to hear you know and I know
the NFLPA and the union's got to you
know negotiations and knew to negotiate
this on the behalf of the players and
all that but you know III do think at
some point we just need to hear where
the players are as a whole and in a
scenario like that like you're saying
because I do think there's gonna be a
big amount of players they're gonna say
I don't care let's just play football it
doesn't matter to me I'm okay we've
already seen a number of players break
social distancing rules and not care and
whatever else so I just would like to
get a gauge of that and then the big
question I have for you Peter just one
thing here you know without XI confident
that the testing would be so prevalent
that it would be able to be handled the
way he explained it to where you're
gonna be able to test all these players
of people in the organization multiple
times a week or every day or twice a day
Chris I asked him I said if and I put
pen to paper if you test every active
player twice a week during the season
and and and and you did that through the
course of the season you started say in
mid-august and you went until the
Superbowl it would be four essential
personnel on every team about two
hundred thousand tests and I asked him
isn't that a little piggish to suggest
that you know all teams you know that
NFL teams could use that when tests are
so minoo people are desperate for tests
in this country and he said right now it
would be but in two three four months
from now we should have enough tests
that plus the fact Chris you know Donald
Trump wants the NFL to play yeah if it
if it means if it means funneling enough
tests to NFL teams to get them to test
twice a week or maybe even more than
that I'm sure that the government is
going to make sure that that happens now
you can say whether that's good bad or
whatever but in my opinion they're going
to have enough tests once the season
starts to to test every player at least
twice a week the question is is the NFL
going to be ready you know to basically
act on the results of those tests in
other words if you have like three or
four guys in a week test positive that
team has got to sit down for 14 days so
that's gonna be a big question and a
couple of things here very quickly Peter
you and I were on the video conference
with the Morris Smith the NFLPA
executive director a few weeks ago and
one of my takeaways from what he said
was we are not going to agree to a
scenario where our players are taking
tests away from the general public so
even if the government decides we're
going to funnel tests to the NFL and the
NFL owners are saying bring them on the
NFLPA may put a line in the sand and say
no we what we refuse and and there's
gonna be a serious element of
negotiation here between the NFL and the
NFLPA and I think this is one of the
reasons why the NFL is treading lightly
publicly they don't want to get ahead of
themselves because they know the Union
eventually is going to have to agree to
whatever the NFL decides to do and once
they start making significant variations
like taking an entire team out of
California for training camp and/or the
full season which may become necessary
that's something the union's going to
have to agree to that's a significant
change in working conditions so I think
that that the union will have a very
strong voice in whether or not the
league is using up tests that could go
to members of the general public but I
also can't in
you to believe that based upon what
folks in the NFL believe there will be
enough testing it seems incomprehensible
now but three months is like three years
or three decades as it relates to our
understanding of the virus and
development of tests and whatnot and I
think we're gonna be stunned when we
look back on May Peter when we get to
August or September hopefully we'll be
stunned hopefully will say holy crap it
was like the Stone Age is back before
Memorial Day but I think that's what the
NFL believes and it makes it a lot
easier to test people not just twice a
week but every day before they walk into
the facility because I think that's
ultimately what they need to aspire to
do Mike the Abbott Labs right now is
developing this 15-minute tests and
right now there have been a bunch of
false negatives with that test but
you're exactly right you think two
months ago Mike two months ago yesterday
I had my last dinner out in New York
City I was shaking hands with people and
so think of what it's going to be like
two months from now three months from
now I doubt that NFL camps will open on
time I doubt that there will be a full
four games in the preseason so let's
just say the NFL we're venting this
right now just says okay all training
camps will open on August 15th
all right so wherever they're held and
if all training camps are held on August
15th which is basically three months
from this week I will be stunned if
there are not enough tests to go around
for most of the people in this country
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports